GameSpot's here at CES 2020 and there's
a ton of game himself to actually check
out on the show even if the focus is on
tech
[Music]
Matt what's the coolest stuff that you
saw so honestly the coolest stuff I saw
at CES was our kid went up spoofs we had
we had an exclusive announcement with
them Burger Time a limited edition
burger town called sorry arcade
captain's coming and they've also got
stuff like NBA jams online multiplayer
Frogger Star Wars sit-down cabinet and a
golden axe cabinet with a bunch of Sega
classics including golden axe revenge of
the Death Adder which is this is the
first time that games been re-released
since the arcades so it's like a pretty
big deal but they've also got digital
pinball which is really exciting because
I'm a huge football fan pinball tables
are huge they break a lot of heart to
move these are a bit more compact but
they seem really cool they've got Zen
studios on it's gonna be rad yeah how
about that
that huge NBA Jam cabinet where he had
to get on the scaffolding to actually
play yeah Nashville's huge as button you
gotta like put your elbow on the turbo
button and then smash the shoot button
with your fists if you want to dunk yeah
it's it's wild yeah it's really cool and
honestly they they got a bunch of the
players for NBA Jam which is like one of
those concerns people have always had
about real releasing that game right
some players won't be there but they
seem to have done a really great job
with it yeah their booth is probably one
of the most exciting things on the show
floor but we also saw a lot of things in
Suites with a lot of companies showing
off their upcoming products one of which
is hyper X and I think the out of all
the things that they should that were
showing off the the best thing was their
switch grips which is the what is a good
charge play clutch yes and I know that
you're very much looking for things on
the switch to improve the grip yeah I'm
always looking for something to make
this much bigger and more like a real
controller and HyperX is releasing this
charge play clutch which is not only a
battery for your switch it also has
magnetic and
you put on to it and it kind of gives
you a more rounded experience with the
switch and honestly like as someone who
has tried all these different grips I
was pretty impressed by it
so that's that's definitely something to
look out for that I would definitely
recommend keeping an eye on sure and I
always see nvidia every year and they
always have something new to show off
this year it was three hundred sixty
Hertz monitors now the thing about their
booth was that they had side-by-side
comparisons playing cs:go with different
monitors using different refresh rates
so you saw firsthand the experience of
jumping from 60 Hertz to three hundred
sixty Hertz even one forty four Hertz
which we use at home and we're like
perfectly happy with and then we got to
the direct comparison between 144 and
360 and that is a difference I was
surprised by I'm like maybe this is
diminishing returns yeah but I did feel
a difference and the way they had their
booth set up with testing csgo they're
like a scoreboard of how many kills you
can get in a certain like trial so you
can actually see the improvement from
increasing your refresh rate and that
was that was a lot of fun because you
know we're csgo players were interested
by how we can actually improve our game
and that was a very good case showing
off that improvement we also went to
razor they always have awesome stuff to
show at CES and the coolest thing they
had this year was for your phone turning
your phone into like more of like a
switch like device because there's stuff
like Project X cloud there's stadia
coming there's a bunch of stuff coming
yeah yeah the the razor kishi is what
they were showing off they also have all
those the the other one that you use a
jungle round stone okay that's out it's
like it's literally just switch joy
Kahn's clipped into your phone yeah
that's really clear and the key she is
sort of an improvement over that and
yeah we were playing Devil May Cry 5
through Project X cloud using the razor
key she and is like this is very close
to a console like experience and you
know razor likes to do all kinds of wild
things like on the show floor they have
that built out racing 360 racing thing
with all kinds of haptic feedback but
this is something that's a lot more
grounded something that you can actually
see yourself using especially as we see
a lot of these services move onto phones
absolutely it's it's it's very exciting
and of course I'll God it was here and
they are showing off their new capture
card that is 4k 60 and it like rivals
some of the stuff that we use a GameSpot
and like that's really exciting because
you don't need anything extra you just
plug in an SD card plug in your console
you're good to go
and like honestly like as streaming gets
bigger as video production gets you know
way bigger industry with YouTube and all
that it's it's really impressive that
they're continuing to make products that
makes sense and they're like nailing
that audience yeah the content creation
is getting a lot more streamlined with
products like this so l got holes at the
top top of their game that was at the
corsair booth of course corsair has a
bunch of keyboards and mice to show off
we saw the new version of the k 95 all
kinds of lights they have light strips
and cases with all kinds of crazy lights
but Elgato in particular is probably the
most sensible thing that i think a lot
of people should be excited about we
always see hyper cane at CES and they
always have dope retro stuff to show off
this year the new thing was the retron
jr. we didn't get to have hands-on with
it because it's still in early
development this is the first time they
showed it to anybody but it's supposed
to play Game Boy Game Boy Advance games
and output to your TV so if you have all
these Game Boy games and you have no way
of playing it on TV unless you got what
is the the Game Boy that
after on the game - yeah yeah unless you
have that you're not gonna be playing
gameboy games on your TV but this thing
is gonna make that a lot easier there's
no release date
there's no pricing on it quite yet
because again it was a prototype and
hybrid kid is always good at you know
focusing on what it is you you want to
get out of your older games making them
easier to play than ever so I'm excited
about this thing and they have a good
track record of doing this thing right
one thing you probably saw baking
headlines at CES this year was the
Alienware concept UFO because it is a PC
that is intended to be used like a
Nintendo switch we actually got hands-on
with it even though this is an early
prototype and it has an 8 inch screen it
has detachable controllers it's running
Windows 10 it has an Intel temp gen CPU
inside of that running it and again this
is early build so there are things you
might notice if you get hands out with
it
like the fans were really loud the
performance was you know a little iffy
but it was it was up and running it was
working and we got to see their their
kind of the Alienware ecosystem how
they're gonna handle PC libraries for
games it looks like a switch library in
in many ways but actually holding the
thing it's pretty big it's bigger than a
switch because it does have an 8 inch
screen it's a little hefty but I mean I
like the design how do you feel that
yeah I mean I agree with you it's it's
there definitely some questions but it's
it's an experiment for them which is
cool because we're not looking at this
thing like it's releasing in November
we're looking at this thing like these
are some cool first steps into this I'm
excited to see what's next we have a
full video on the Alienware concept UFO
so you should check that out after
you're done watching this AMD always has
a big splash at CES but for our purposes
we got to talk to some of the developers
of the AMD Radeon 5600 XT which is a
good mid-range card it's not the most
exciting thing but I think it solidifies
what AMD is trying to do with the with
the graphics processing and really
taking care of the mid to low range and
giving a lot of people options there
whereas Nvidia their main competitor
is coming out with like super high-end
stuff and ray-tracing and all that so
I'm still impressed by how AMT is able
to corner that market with even more
products absolutely it last but not
least we saw creative labs it was our
last demo of the show and honestly one
of the most impressive things I thought
see yes it's this technology where
basically it makes headphones sound like
a surround system in your room
and this sounded better than virtual
surround sound yeah I was really
impressed our demo literally was we sat
in a room they said pearl the head with
us know when you hear the sound and they
we were like when is gonna play I'm just
playing the speakers and then it was
like oh wow those are the headphones
yeah it's really exciting technology
sounds great
they're coming up with a gaming headset
these are the Super X PI air they're a
bluetooth headphone got a microphone all
the good stuff and honestly I'm like we
tested out the gaming headset it's
exciting we played some Cisco with it
and it's it's got some really good
potential to be just absolutely
fantastic headphones and of course we
are going to be testing out a bunch of
these so stay tuned game talk to that so
those are our favorite things that we
saw at CES 2020 it really was a show of
demoing side-by-side the potential of a
lot of the products that we saw and
we're covering it on games Wacom so be
sure to check out our website for all
the coverage on CS 2020 thanks for
watching
[Music]